so here's a problem I just have to tell
you right now whenever I meet somebody
who I really like I mean who I really
admire I'm a complete idiot at dinner so
I mean complete idiot so in a way I
would not ever like to go to dinner with
anyone but I have to say that when
Samuel Beckett died I felt like are you
kidding I was supposed to be coming your
friend now did you die without that
happening I mean it was just an onion Oh
was unspoken idea I had had my whole
life that I would of course meet Samuel
back in any of course he would like me
and of course we would become friends so
but of course if I did meet him I'd act
like a complete idiot yeah and if and I
was supposed to meet Fineman but if
luckily I didn't because then I I don't
have that I you know how you know how
people say that pain you can't remember
but embarrassment you can so I'm really
glad I didn't meet finally imagine
meeting Fineman and then you know having
nothing but love and at all energy
scales for him and and then being an
idiot and then remembering that your
whole life so so yeah so so I don't
really want to meet these guys at all
but more but I think I'd be less
embarrassed by Beckett than Fineman